Heute geht die Expedition
ins Unbekannte extrem früh los.
Es ist noch nicht mal 6 Uhr.
Ich bin auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber bereit für alles.
Alles, was vor mir liegt,
ist eine Blackbox.
Nämlich diese hier.
Das hier ist ein Tramplan
von Zürich. Das kenne ich.
Und ... oh!
Oh!
Dieses Knistern macht mich am
frühen Morgen unendlich glücklich.
Es geht an die Verenastrasse,
und zwar mit dem Bus Nr. 70.
Und auf geht's ins Unbekannte.
* Jazzige Musik *
Einen Hinweis gibt es. Ich alleine
kann nicht so viele Gipfeli essen.
Es sind neun Gipfeli.
Auf Mona warten also acht Leute.
Aber was sind das für Leute?
(Durchsage) Verenastrasse.
Wo rollen wir denn jetzt hin?
Hier ist ja gar nichts.
Soll ich einfach irgendwo klingeln
und mit denen dann frühstücken?
Das wäre vielleicht nett.
Hallo zusammen.
Kennst du mich? Hallo. Mona.
Ivan.
- Ivan? Ah, Mona.
Hoi.
- Mein Name ist Diogo.
Diogo?
- Ja. - Super.
Und ihr holt mich ab?
Abholen?
- Ja, abholen.
Soll ich mit euch mitkommen?
Okay.
Gut. Gehen wir!
Mona weiss nicht recht,
mit wem sie da mitgeht.
Für einmal ist sie sprachlos.
Was ist dort, wo wir hingehen?
Dort?
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Ah, zu ...
Okay. Bist du gehörlos?
Ah. Okay.
Aber du kannst Lippen lesen?
Ja.
- Ah, okay. Gut. Super.
Bravo, Mona. Du hast schnell
herausgefunden, was hier anders ist.
Das Ziel ist eine Wohngruppe
für gehörlose Jugendliche.
Danke.
Ah.
Ist das eine Wohnung?
- Essen.
Essen? Ah, Frühstück!
Ah. Frühstück!
Gipfeli. Ah!
Hallo.
Auch Betreuerin Sarah Scheiber
hört nichts.
Hallo zusammen. Ich bin Mona.
Es freut mich sehr.
Hier sind die Gipfeli für euch,
zum Frühstück.
Danke.
- Sehr gerne. Sehr gerne.
Ich lege sie hierher.
Essen wir Frühstück! Morgenessen.
Also.
Für Mona eine besondere Challenge.
Wie schlägt sie sich in einem Umfeld,
wo sie nicht einfach reden kann -
so wie sonst?
Drei Tage unter Gehörlosen leben.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Musst du jetzt in die Schule?
Jetzt dann in die Schule?
Du? Schule?
(Erster Kontaktversuch mit Abdulai.)
Schule? Du?
Ja.
(Betreuerin) In 15 Min.
- Ja. Okay.
Wo ist die Schule?
Auf der anderen Seite?
Es ist ... ähm ... eine ruhige Welt.
Ich werde an den Anschlag kommen.
Es ist wie eine Fremdsprache.
Ich verstehe einfach nichts.
Ich bin auf Sarah angewiesen,
die für mich übersetzt.
Also ...
Für mich ist es speziell. Ich ...
Ich kenne es noch nicht.
Ich bin ein bisschen unsicher.
(Schwer verständlich)
Bei uns ist es auch immer so.
Wenn wir mit Hörenden arbeiten,
sprechen auch alle.
Und wir verstehen auch nichts.
- Ja.
Aber ich finde es gut,
dass du da bist.
Damit du spürst ...
... wie es ist,
wenn man immer ausgeschlossen ist.
Alle verstehen sich. Und man sitzt
da und denkt: "Was läuft hier?"
"Ich verstehe es nicht."
- Eben.
Ich werde merken, wie das ist.
- Ja, genau.
(Die Schule liegt 10 Min. entfernt
im Zürcher Stadtteil Wollishofen.)
(Ich gehe einfach mal mit.)
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
worüber sie sprechen.
In dieser Sprache
bin ich der Analphabet.
Ich fühle mich
ein wenig ausgeschlossen.
Da lang?
(Das Schulhaus Hans Asper.)
(Die gehörlosen Jugendlichen
gehen hier in die Sekundarschule,
in die sog. SEK3.)
* Schulglocke *
(Ich werde
vom Lehrer Emanuel Nay erwartet.)
(Auch er ist gehörlos.)
Guten Morgen, Mona.
- Guten Morgen. Ich bin Mona.
Ich bin Emanuel.
- Es freut mich sehr.
Gebärdensprachlehrer.
- Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
(In der SEK3
wird bilingual unterrichtet,
d.h., in Gebärdensprache
und in Lautsprache -
von zwei Lehrpersonen.)
(Frau) Also. Alle, die hier
anwesend sind, haben Gebärdennamen.
Und warum ist das so?
Bei den Gehörlosen ist das
gleich wie bei den Indianern.
Man beobachtet den Menschen,
schaut, was zu ihm passt,
und gibt ihm einen Gebärdennamen.
Mein Gebärdenname ist ...
Emanuel.
Früher hatte ich einen Wusch Haare.
Ihr seht, dass Mona hier ist.
Sie hat keinen Gebärdennamen.
Die Schüler wehren sich.
Sie sagen: "Wir haben
schon einen Namen, der passt."
Ihr seid schnell.
- Mein Gebärdenname. Achtung!
Das ging schnell.
- Also. Erzählt mal!
In der WG
haben wir uns Gedanken gemacht.
Bei Mona sind ihre Augen
das Auffälligste. Die strahlen.
Und darum
wollen wir dir diesen Namen geben.
Oh. Danke. Vielen Dank.
(Mona und Dolmetscherin)
Mein Name ...
Und dann gebärdest du deinen Namen.
Also.
... Name Mona.
Genau. Bravo.
- Ah, das ist Klatschen?
Das ist der Applaus, ja.
Das ist ... ja.
Klatschen hört ja niemand.
Und bei dir, Xenja?
Ah, wegen den Locken.
Mein Name ist Ivan. Ich habe mir
immer den Kopf geschlagen,
hatte Beulen und Narben.
Und darum ...
Mit dem I von Ivan
zeigt er sich an die Stirn.
Ja.
(Nach dem Gebärdennamen
bekomme ich noch etwas:
eine Spezialaufgabe.)
Ich muss jetzt also
richtig arbeiten? Ich muss ...
Ja, arbeiten.
Vielleicht in der Zwischenzeit,
am Abend und in der Nacht
kannst du noch üben.
Meine Aufgabe ist es also, dass ich
bis Freitag all diese Begriffe kann.
Genau.
Und diese dann der Klasse sagen.
"Herzlichen Dank".
Du kannst bereits deinen Namen.
M-o-n-a.
Ich denke, du lernst das schnell.
- Ja. Ich hoffe es.
Bis am Freitag.
(Übermorgen
muss ich also einen Vortrag halten,
und zwar
komplett in Gebärdensprache.)
Hier ist im Moment die Nr. 28.
(Das Schulhaus Hans Asper
ist keine Schule nur für Gehörlose.)
(Es ist eine gewöhnliche Sek.)
(Die Gehörlosen und
andere hörbehinderte Jugendliche
werden separat, aber auch
in den Regelklassen unterrichtet.)
(So findet ein Austausch statt.)
(Es gibt sogar ein Freifach,
wo hörende Schüler
Gebärdensprache lernen können.)
Warum belegt ihr
das Freifach Gebärdensprache?
Ich mache das,
weil es interessant ist,
eine neue Sprache zu lernen.
Sehr viele in diesem Schulhaus
gebärden.
Deshalb ist es spannend,
zu sehen, was sie gebärden.
Sie zu verstehen.
- Ja.
Sonst steht man daneben und denkt:
"Tja, toll. Ich verstehe nichts."
(Die Gebärdensprache wurde lange
als "Affensprache" verunglimpft.)
(Bis in die 90er-Jahre
war sie an gewissen
Gehörlosenschulen verboten.)
(Man hatte Angst,
dass die Kinder die Lautsprache
nicht richtig lernen.)
(Heute fängt man früh
mit Gebärdensprache an.)
(Das ist aber nicht einfach,
denn 90 % der gehörlosen Kinder
haben hörende Eltern.)
Und wenn du als Elternteil
ein Kind bekommst,
das gehörlos ist,
und du kannst keine Gebärdensprache.
Die können nicht in die Schule,
um das zu lernen.
Wo lernen die Eltern ...
- Es gibt Eltern, die offen sind,
die Gebärdensprache lernen möchten,
weil sie eine gute Beziehung haben
und kommunizieren möchten.
Es gibt Eltern,
die das nicht wollen, die sagen:
"Unsere Sprache ist Deutsch."
Das Kind muss sich anpassen.
Das ist unterschiedlich.
Meine Beobachtung ist,
dass leider viele Eltern
die Gebärdensprache nicht lernen.
Das finde ich ein bisschen schade.
Deswegen
bin ich auch nicht überrascht,
dass viele gehörlose Kinder sehr
gerne in die Gehörlosenschule gehen.
Sie sagen:
"Fünf Wochen Sommerferien, ach ..."
Die freuen sich weniger.
Weil es zu Hause
wenig Kommunikation gibt.
Aha. Hier können sie gut reden,
weil alle ihre Sprache sprechen.
Ja, genau.
Sie können nicht mehr kommunizieren.
Nach den Sommerferien freuen sie
sich, in die Schule zu gehen.
Das ist nicht bei allen so,
aber bei einigen.
Das tut mir ein bisschen weh.
Vielen Dank.
Es war super.
Wie macht man es im Alltag?
Viele Leute haben
keine Ahnung von Gebärdensprache.
Wenn man
auf einen Gehörlosen trifft,
was soll man machen und was nicht?
Es braucht zuerst eine Überwindung.
Auf der Seite des Gehörlosen
und des Hörenden.
Beide brauchen Überwindung
für einen ersten Schritt.
Wenn man dann einzelne Gebärden
kann, ist es einfach.
Hallo. Wie geht's? Gut.
- Das ist schon gut.
Wie geht's?
Gut.
Hallo.
Wer kommt denn da?
- Das ist meine Frau.
Aha. Ich bin Mona.
Es freut mich. Hallo.
Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Und unser Sohn.
- Hey, hallo.
Hey, Aurin.
- Aurin.
Sprichst du auch Gebärdensprache?
Oder ...
Ja. Sie ist zu 100 % gehörlos.
100 %.
Und ist euer Sohn
gehörlos oder hörend?
Hörend.
- Ah, wow. Das ist interessant.
Interessant. Ja.
Na du? Bist du etwas schüchtern?
Er gebärdet auch.
Wir kommunizieren zu Hause
in Gebärdensprache.
Gehen wir!
- Darf ich euch rausbegleiten?
(Was für eine Familie!)
(Ihre Einladung, sie morgen
bei sich zu Hause zu besuchen,
nehme ich sehr gerne an.)
(Aber zuerst
habe ich Kochdienst im Hort.)
(Mit mir eingeteilt
sind auch die beiden,
die mich am Morgen vom Bus
abgeholt haben: Diogo und Ivan.)
(Viel geredet wird nicht -
auch nicht in Gebärdensprache.)
(Die Hände
werden zum Schälen gebraucht.)
Du ... früher ... dein Beruf?
Mein Beruf? Mein Beruf ist das hier.
Ich bin Moderatorin im Fernsehen.
Ich spreche.
Die ganze Zeit.
Ein seltsamer Beruf für euch.
Und ich mache ...
Ich mache auch Radio.
Radio.
Das ist noch schwieriger. Ähm ...
Wie sagt man Radio? Ähm ...
Äh ... Diogo ...
Wa... Äh ...
Auch sprechen, aber im Radio.
Radio. Ja.
Wir haben uns nicht verstanden,
aber ja.
(Junge) Guten Appetit.
- Danke.
(Im Hort
essen alle Schüler gemeinsam.)
(Aber heute, am Mittwoch,
sind fast nur Gehörlose da.)
Guten Appetit.
(Zurück von der Schule
in der Wohngruppe.)
(Hier leben unter der Woche
die Jugendlichen,
für die der Schulweg zu weit wäre.)
(Xenja und Abdulai
sitzen vor dem Computer.)
(Daneben schaut Rebekka auf Insta-
gram die Fotos ihrer Freunde an.)
(Social Media funktioniert tipptopp,
auch ohne Ton.)
(Am Abend chillt meine Teenie-WG.)
(Nur ich muss Hausaufgaben machen.)
(Ein Vortrag in Gebärdensprache -
das ist für mich diese Gebärde hier:
schwierig.)
Zukunft.
In Zukunft ist es geschafft.
- Zukunft. Ja.
Ah, ja. Auf Wiedersehen.
Das ist einfach.
Einfach.
Ich habe schon ein bisschen geübt.
Am Freitag habe ich Prüfung.
Prüfung? - Ja.
Am Freitag muss ich alles können.
Aber ihr habt mir gut geholfen.
Danke.
(Ich komme ins Gespräch mit Marcel,
der hier zu Besuch ist.)
Und deine Eltern
können ein bisschen gebärden?
Ein bisschen? Nicht so gut?
Ja.
- Ja.
Nicht super. Zu wenig.
Mein Vater
kann nicht super gebärden.
Nur sprechen.
Meine Mama kann es besser.
Aber nicht alle Gebärden.
Ja.
- Nur wenige Sachen.
Ja. Wenn du dich also
richtig unterhalten willst,
musst du dich hier
mit den Leuten unterhalten -
mit deinen Freunden.
Nur so ...
* Er spricht unverständlich. *
Aber nicht mit Fremden.
- Ja.
(Hier unter sich können sie
ganz normale Teenager sein.)
(Und das Vorurteil, dass es
unter Gehörlosen immer ruhig sei,
hat sich für mich schon in der
ersten Nacht in der WG erledigt.)
(Wieder im Schulhaus Hans Asper.)
(Ich und meine Finger
kämpfen sich immer noch
durch den Grundwortschatz
der Gebärdensprache.)
Ich komme ziemlich auf die Welt.
Ich bin es gewohnt,
dass ich sonst mit Reden und Sprache
überall durchkomme.
Auf der ganzen Welt.
Irgendwie geht es immer.
Hier stehe ich
mit meinen "Waffen" an.
Das ist kein gutes Gefühl. Aber ich
glaube, es ist eine gute Erfahrung.
(Aber jetzt gibt es Abwechslung.)
Hallo, Mona.
Hallo.
(Lehrer Emanuel Nay holt mich ab
für den Besuch bei ihnen zu Hause.)
(Er wohnt gleich beim Schulhaus.)
(Emanuel hat sich gewünscht,
dass bei unserem Gespräch eine
Gebärdendolmetscherin dabei ist.)
(So können er und seine Frau
Patricia sich genauer ausdrücken.)
"Willkommen", sagt sie.
Hallo, Patricia.
(Emanuel hat Patricia auf einer Rei-
se durch Westafrika kennengelernt.)
(Sie haben sich verliebt,
Patricia kam in die Schweiz,
und sie haben geheiratet.)
Und dann kam Aurin.
(Hier kommen zwei Welten zusammen:
sie aus Ghana, er aus Laax.)
(Emanuel ist
mit drei Schwestern aufgewachsen.)
(Aber er ist der Einzige
in der Familie, der nichts hört.)
(Jetzt verstehe ich auch
seinen Gebärdennamen.)
(Er hatte wirklich
einmal viele Haare.)
(Emanuel
ging in die gewöhnliche Schule
und fing erst spät an,
mit den Händen zu reden.)
Mit 14 hatte ich das erste Mal
Kontakt mit der Gebärdensprache.
Da habe ich sie gelernt.
Wirklich sattelfest
in der Gebärdensprache
wurde ich
in der Berufsschule für Gehörlose.
Da hatte ich viele Kontakte.
Ich ging an den Wochenenden aus.
Ich hatte viel Kontakt
und saugte wie ein Staubsauger
die Gebärden auf.
Das war für meine
Identitätsentwicklung sehr wichtig.
Ich habe mich
plötzlich vollwertig gefühlt -
mit einer Sprache,
die ich benutzen kann.
Wie ein Baum,
der plötzlich Wurzeln hat.
Vorher war ich immer unsicher.
Ich musste mich immer anpassen.
Danach war ich viel selbstsicherer.
Die Lebensqualität
hat sich massiv gesteigert.
Patricia, wann hast du
Gebärdensprache gelernt?
In der Schule, wo ich gewohnt habe.
In der Schule habe ich angefangen,
Gebärdensprache zu lernen.
Ich habe auch
im Internat übernachtet.
Wie alt warst du?
Ungefähr acht oder neun Jahre alt.
Ich war dort in der Schule und hatte
jeden Tag Kontakt mit Gehörlosen.
Ich habe
die Gebärdensprache gelernt.
Und dann
haben wir uns kennengelernt
und haben uns verliebt.
Wie war das, als ihr wusstet,
dass ihr ein Kind bekommt?
Habt ihr euch überlegt: Wird es
hörend oder wird es gehörlos?
Es war mir völlig egal,
ob es gehörlos oder hörend ist.
Wenn es gehörlos ist,
ist es kein Problem,
wenn es hörend ist auch nicht.
In jedem Fall
lernt das Kind Gebärdensprache.
Wenn er gehörlos gewesen wäre,
hätten wir vielleicht entschieden,
nach Afrika zu gehen
und ihn dort zu schulen.
In der Schweiz
gibt es immer weniger Gehörlose.
Das hätte ich mir vorstellen können.
- Aha.
Ich habe vergessen ... Möchtest du
was trinken? Tut mir leid.
Ja ... und ...
Ja, gerne.
- Was möchtest du? - Wasser.
Wasser.
(Emanuel spricht so gut,
dass ich erst jetzt realisiere,
dass unser Deutsch
für ihn wie eine Fremdsprache ist.)
(Sein Sohn Aurin
lernt die Lautsprache später
v.a. von seinen Spielkameraden.)
Ich habe festgestellt,
dass ihr mehr Augenmenschen seid.
Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, genau. Das stimmt.
Wir sind ganz stark Augenmenschen,
wir Gehörlosen.
Wenn man das Gehör nicht hat,
ist man zu 100 %
auf die Augen angewiesen.
Wenn wir keine Augen hätten,
wären wir total behindert.
Dann würden wir nichts verstehen.
Für uns ist das extrem wichtig.
Das Hörgerät
unterstützt vielleicht 15-20 %.
Ich kriege die Geräusche mit, aber
Sprache nicht - über ein Hörgerät.
Ich kann nicht telefonieren.
Ich höre vielleicht,
dass sich da was tut im Telefon,
aber ich verstehe nichts.
Wenn ich die Hörgeräte abnehme,
bin ich zu 100 % gehörlos.
Dann kann ich super schlafen.
Aber ... halt! Da gibt es ein
Problem. Was ist, wenn Aurin weint?
Ihr schlaft super. Ihr hört nichts.
Wie macht ihr das?
Per Blinkanlage
werden wir informiert,
dass er gestillt werden möchte
oder dass er wach ist.
Das vibriert oder blinkt dann.
Es gibt beide Möglichkeiten.
Speziell für ...
- Dann kann ich ihn zu mir nehmen.
Oder er schläft bei uns in der Nähe
und zupft an uns.
Wir tragen das am Handgelenk.
Und wenn er weint ...
- ... dann vibriert es.
Super!
(Die schönste Nachricht
erfahre ich zum Schluss:
In einigen Monaten
gibt es ein Geschwister für Aurin.)
Es hat mich sehr gefreut.
(Emanuel hat mit knapp 40
seinen Platz gefunden.)
(Aber der Weg seiner Schüler
der SEK3 ist noch ungewiss.)
(Sie müssen lernen,
in einer Welt zu leben,
in der wir Hörenden
den Ton angeben.)
(Genau deshalb arbeitet Ivan
einen Morgen pro Woche
in einem Käsegeschäft.)
(Er ist im letzten Schuljahr
und sucht eine Lehrstelle.)
Dann machen wir wieder
Fixfertig-Fondue.
Und dann ... schneidest du
zuerst Gruyere und Vacherin.
(Schon ein paar Jugendliche der SEK3
haben hier geschnuppert.)
(Der Chef des Käsegeschäfts
hat so weit gute Erfahrungen gemacht
mit den Gehörlosen.)
Das einzige Problem,
das wir bis jetzt mit ihnen hatten,
ist, dass keiner Käse mochte.
Ich weiss nicht, wieso.
Aber es ist so.
Auch Ivan mag keinen Käse.
Er möchte lieber Elektriker werden.
Ivan, was sind deine Erfahrungen,
wenn du jetzt
in der Arbeitswelt tätig wirst?
Ich arbeite hier mit Käse.
Ich arbeite nicht
mit der Kundschaft.
Ich arbeite v.a. mit dem Käse.
Das gefällt mir gut.
Wäre es mit der Kundschaft
schwierig für dich?
Ja.
Verstehen die Leute von Anfang an,
dass du
ein Problem mit dem Gehör hast,
sonst aber bist
wie alle anderen jungen Leute?
Wenn die Hörenden realisieren,
dass ich gehörlos bin,
sagen sie jeweils:
"Ah, du bist taub."
Magst du dieses Wort nicht?
Nein.
* Sie lachen. *
("Taub" ist für viele Gehörlose
ein Schimpfwort.)
(Wieder etwas gelernt.)
(Wie schon,
dass Lippenlesen einfacher geht,
je deutlicher man selbst
Hochdeutsch spricht.)
(In der Logopädie
wird das Verstehen und Sprechen
von Lautsprache geschult.)
Links ist der.
(Tamara übt Deutsch - für sie
als Gehörlose eine Fremdsprache.)
(Auch Lippenlesen trainiert sie.)
(Das braucht viel Konzentration
und ist sehr anstrengend.)
Wenn du mich nicht verstehst,
fragst du. - Okay.
Sie versuchte, sich an
irgendetwas Hilfreiches zu erinnern,
das der Bewerbungstrainer
ihr geraten hatte.
(Die SEK3 will
keine geschützte Werkstatt sein.)
(Aber die meiste Zeit
sind die Gehörlosen unter sich -
in der Schule und der WG.)
(Ich frage mich: Sind sie fast
zu weit weg von der hörenden Welt?)
(Andererseits: Viele der Jungen hier
tragen ein Hörgerät
oder sogar ein Implantat wie Diogo -
ein Cochlea-Implantat, CI.)
(Dieses simuliert das Hören.)
(Kann man heutzutage
Gehörlose zu Hörenden machen?)
(Und wollen das
die Gehörlosen überhaupt?)
(Mit vielen Fragen
komme ich zurück in die WG.)
Hallo. Geht es gut?
Gut?
(Ich mache eine kurze Recherche,
was dieses CI,
das Cochlea-Implantat,
eigentlich genau ist.)
(Beim CI werden Tonsignale direkt
in die Gehörschnecke weitergeleitet,
in die Cochlea.)
(Es braucht eine Operation dazu,
die man
möglichst im Babyalter machen muss.)
(Im Netz findet man auch Beispiele,
wie man mit einem solchen CI hört.)
Hören wir uns Stimmen an!
(Frau) Ich bin
im Verkehr stecken geblieben.
Er muss seine Verwandten besuchen.
- Und mit einem CI ...
(Verzerrte, künstliche Stimme)
... stecken geblieben.
Er muss seine Verwandten besuchen.
Ui! Nein!
Man möchte eigentlich lieber nicht
so klingen im Ohr von jemandem.
Aber wenn man die Wahl hat,
zwischen gar nichts hören
und Menschen, die so klingen ...
(Knarzende, verzerrte Stimme) ...
Auskunft geben. Beeil dich bitte!
(Für Eltern eines gehörlosen Babys
sicher kein einfacher Entscheid,
ob man
eine CI-Operation machen möchte.)
Und von euch hat niemand ein CI?
Nein.
- Warum nicht?
Ein CI hilft nicht einfach immer.
Es gibt positive,
aber auch negative Seiten.
Für Schwerhörige
kann es sicher helfen,
aber für Gehörlose
ist es wohl keine so grosse Hilfe.
Bist du gehörlos?
Ich bin gehörlos.
- Okay. Ja.
Ich hatte Hörapparate,
aber die halfen nicht.
Ich hörte nur Geräusche,
konnte aber keine Intonation
oder einzelne Buchstaben
oder Laute hören.
Ich habe nur gehört,
dass ein Auto vorbeifährt.
Das war alles. Ich konnte
keine Laute unterscheiden.
Deshalb legte ich es auch ab.
* Alle lachen. *
Meine ganze Familie ist gehörlos.
- Ah, okay.
Wir mit gehörlosen Eltern sind
auch stolz darauf, gehörlos zu sein.
Die Eltern und auch die Kinder.
Gehörlos zu sein macht uns stolz.
Wir haben unsere eigene Kultur,
eine Gehörlosenidentität.
Es gibt immer mehr Gehörlose,
die integriert werden.
Das ist ein grosser Trend.
Oft haben sie vielleicht ... Ich
weiss nicht, ob sie Freunde haben.
Sie sind
in einer hörenden Welt aufgewachsen.
Später, mit 20, 25 oder 30
merken sie, dass sie
Bedarf an Gebärdensprache haben.
Dann machen sie den Wechsel
in die Gehörlosengemeinschaft.
Das beobachte ich sehr oft.
Kinder, die integriert sind,
können vielleicht besser reden,
sie haben einen besseren Zugang
zur hörenden Welt.
Aber es ist ein Identitätsmerkmal.
Und das fehlt ihnen.
Sie haben es nie mitbekommen, weil
sie immer unter Hörenden lebten.
Sie sind nicht gleich wie Hörende.
Wie ist es für euch?
Wenn ihr könntet, würdet ihr lieber
zu Hause bei den Eltern wohnen
und in eine Regelschule gehen,
oder ...
... findet ihr das hier besser?
Hier. Es ist viel besser hier.
- Das sagt Ivan?
Warum?
Hier hat es Gehörlose.
Es ist sozialer.
Man kann sich
in der gleichen Sprache unterhalten.
(Ich habe immer gedacht,
je mehr Integration, desto besser.)
(Aber die Gehörlosen selbst
sehen das anders.)
(In der hörenden Welt
bleiben sie immer ein wenig fremd,
egal,
wie stark sie sich anstrengen.)
(Sie haben Angst,
ihre eigene Sprache zu verlieren -
und damit auch den Ort,
an dem sie sich wohlfühlen.)
(Freitagmorgen,
alle packen ihre Sachen.)
(Übers Wochenende
geht es nach Hause zu den Eltern.)
(Aber vorher ist nochmals Schule.)
(Für mich kommt bald
die Stunde der Wahrheit.)
(Letzte Gelegenheit,
meinen Vortrag nochmals zu lernen.)
(Und ausgerechnet die Gebärde für
"lernen" kann ich immer noch nicht.)
(Xenja macht Sandwiches
für den Pausenkiosk.)
(Sie ist im letzten Schuljahr -
wie Ivan und Diogo.)
(Xenja hat unter ihren Locken
ein CI versteckt.)
(Sie kann sehr gut sprechen.)
Hast du schon eine Lehrstelle?
Ich bin nur schnuppern gegangen.
Aber eine Lehrstelle
habe ich noch nicht.
Hast du ein bisschen Angst,
dass du keine findest?
Ich habe schon ein bisschen Angst.
Aber die Leute sagen immer,
sie hätten keine Zeit.
Aha.
- Sie verschieben es immer.
Das ist ein bisschen mühsam.
- Ja.
Sie geben dir keine Chance.
Aber ...
Ich hoffe, dass es noch klappt,
bis zum Sommer.
Was für eine Lehrstelle suchst du?
- Gärtnerei.
Gärtnerei.
- Ah, Gärtnerei.
Gärtnerin willst du werden?
- Ja.
Es macht mich traurig,
dass Menschen wie Xenja
sich nicht einmal vorstellen dürfen.
Also. Binde das da fest!
(Der Pausenkiosk der SEK3
ist ein Übungsfeld,
um Hemmschwellen abzubauen.)
(Hier kommen hörende und gehörlose
Schüler in direkten Kontakt -
auch wenn es nur
um dein Einkauf des Znüni geht.)
* Stimmengewirr *
Was soll ich denn sagen?
Habe ich doch.
Ist es schwierig, zu reden?
Ich bin ...
Das ist mein zweiter Tag hier.
* Mona lacht. * Ah, du hattest
noch nie mit Gehörlosen zu tun.
Nein.
- Es ist aber auch schwierig.
Du dachtest dir:
"Was mache ich jetzt?"
Ich war überfordert.
- Ja.
Gibt es etwas, von dem du findest,
könnten wir Hörende besser machen?
Ja, sicher. Die Offenheit.
Es ist schön, zu sehen,
dass es gemeinsam gut funktioniert,
dass man gemeinsam zur Schule
gehen kann - das ist toll.
Schöne Pause!
- Danke. - Tschüss.
Es ist genau das.
Man steht hier und ist ... hilflos.
Was macht man,
wenn sie einen nicht verstehen?
Es ist cool, sie nimmt das gelassen.
(Weniger gelassen
nehme ich es gleich.)
(Ich muss nämlich meinen Vortrag
in Gebärdensprache halten,
den ich drei Tage lang geübt habe.)
Ein besonderer Moment.
... präsentieren.
(Ich habe Prüfungsangst - zum
ersten Mal wieder seit 25 Jahren.)
* Sie räuspert sich. *
(Einige Schüler) Bravo!
(Meine paar Brocken Gebärdensprache
sind in meiner Gehörlosenklasse
angekommen.)
(Für einen kurzen Moment
bin ich ganz Teil ihrer Welt.)
Erstaunlich.
- (Einige Schüler) Ja.
Gut geübt.
Super!
(Wir machen noch ein Abschlussfoto.)
(Was ich von hier mitnehme:
Noch nie habe ich Menschen
beim Reden
so häufig in die Augen geschaut
wie in diesen drei Tagen.)
(Das ist ein schönes Gefühl
für alle Menschen -
egal, ob sie hören oder nicht.)
* Jubel *